[موسيقى]
جرائد جرايد هذه كانت الكلمات اللي اصيح
بيها بالخضاره بالعشار وهي اول شغله
اشتغلت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كان عمر 17 سنه
اشتغلتها ما بعد 2003
كانت الجرايد تيجي عن طريق الجيش
البريطاني لبس الزمان
والقبس والوطن الكويتيه
استمرت هاي تقريبا سته اشهر من بعدها
من بعدها اشتغلت بالجرايد والمجلات
الاجنبيه ام كانت مستخدمه تيجي عن طريق
الجيش البريطاني كانت التايم والي ميوزك
والجاردين وهواي مجلات وجرائد كانت عندي
وسطيه بشارع الجزائر
استمرت تقريبا هاي الشغله الله يستر
تقريبا ابيع مجلات وجرائد بالاضافه الى
هواي شغلات انت تشتغلها بهذا الوقت
من بعدها صار عندي اهتمام بالكاميرات هاي
الكاميرات نفس الحاله كانت تيجي عن طريق
الجيش البريطاني يعني كلها مستخدمه مكسره
تعرفوني يدبونهم في همم انا اشترينهن
وابدل
همم شاشه على على كاميرا ثانيه لزوم اكثر
شيء كان يجي مكسور هما ابدلها
وبالاضافه ابدي اصور اصور بين هاي
الكاميرا اول كاميرا صورت بها وهي هاي لحد
الان محتفظ بيها همم
هناك كانت اقدر اقول هي بداياتي بالتصوير
والفتره اللي قبلها مالت الجرايد والمجلات
صارت البدايه للتغذيه البصريه للتصوير
التغذيه البصريه كلش ضروري بعالم التصوير
راحت تغني صور
وراح تستلهم من الصور
شلون طورت نفسي مثل ما قلت لكم كانت
بالبدايه بصريه من بعدها التصوير من ضلي
تشتري الكاميرا ظليت ابدي اصور صارت عندي
استمراريه صارت عندي حب للتصوير هاي
الصوره صورتها يمكن بال 2012
[موسيقى]
عرفت شلون اوظف التكوين عرفت شوكت الوقت
المناسب للصوره شنو ممكن اصور من البيئه
اللي انا عايش بيها وشلون اقدر اصبر حتى
احصل على هيك صوره
هاي الصوره من نفس المكان من شط العرب بس
غيرت الزاويه مالتي
غيرت الاعدادات الكاميرا قدرت تحصل على
هاي الصوره هم يعني من نفس المكان شط
العرب اللي هو همم كان
الكنز الحقيقي الي لين انا تقريبا كل يوم
اروح على شط العرب وكل يوم اشوف صوره
جديده وكل يوم اصور صوره جديده من شط
العرب
حالي حال كل شويه من الشباب العراقيين انا
عندي شهاده خرجت من كليه التربيه الرياضيه
طبعا بالمناسبه يعني الشهاده مالتي مهم
التصوير ما درست التصوير ولا درست الصحافه
انا خريج اعداديه الصناعه خرجت من اعداديه
الصناعه راحت على التربيه الرياضيه
والمناسبه لما تخرجت من التربيه الرياضيه
وذاك اليوم باقي نقالي وانا حتى شبرين ما
قدرت
فقلت لازم تعين تعيين الحكومه
ضليت اقدم من تخرجت من سنه 2012 من كليه
تربيه رياضيه لحد سنه 2019
جربت التعيين الحكومي وتعيينه وهذا كان
اليوم الاول الي رايح انا بالسياره مالت
الخط
واشتغلت
بالقطاعه اللي يحلم به تقريبا اغلب الشباب
اللي هو القطاع النفطي
تشوفون هنا الفرحه رايح ورايح للخط اللي
اللي يودي الموظفين وهذا فتشان انجاز كلش
استمرت تقريبا شهرين وما تحملت الحاله
تخيلوا انا مصور
وخلال شهرين انا ما مصور ولا صوره
بالوظيفه الحكومي فقلت هذا مو مكاني
هذا كان اليوم الاخير لي بالوظيفه
الحكوميه من خلال شهرين بس
رجعت بالخط العفو هنا انا رايح انا بالخط
وثقت هذه الصوره
راحت قدمت استقالتي ورجعت بسياره رجعت
للعشاء اشتريت جريده حتى رجح هذا الواهس
وارجح هذا الشغب والحب اللي بالتصوير اللي
تقريبا
دخلت للتصوير الصحفي سنه 2019
جربت اشتغل بوكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
احتاجه مصور هنا بالبصره وكانت البدايات
التظاهرات انا كمصور سابقا ما كانت عندي
تجربه بالتصوير الصحفي ااا ما كنت تعرف
شنو التصوير الصحفي وقبل انت تنزل على
احداث ساخنه مثل التظاهرات هذا كان التحدي
الحقيقي الي كان لازم انقل صوره حقيقيه من
التظاهرات
وبالاضافه لازم مو صوره اخبار يعني انا
بالنسبه ليك كمصور فني لازم اخلي لميستي
بالصوره الصحفيه من خلال التظاهرات وهذا
كان كل شيء صعب يعني انت بالصوره الفنيه
ممكن ممكن همم ترتب الاضاءه بكيفك تعدل
عليها بالفوتوشوب حتى تطلع صوره صوره حلوه
بالتصوير الصحفي هذا كله ما يصير عندنا
دخلت بالتصوير الصحفي وبديت اتعامل ويا
الاحداث
بطريقتي الفنيه بالاضافه الى الصعوبات
اللي واجهتها كانت يعني صعوبات كلش هواي
من ضمنها الشارع ما كان يتقبل الكاميرا
الخاصه المتظاهرين انت ليش تصورنا القوات
الامنيه نفس الحاله في هنانهم كانت ما
عندي هويه للممارسه المهنه في همم
على طول سنه تقريبا انا كانت همم النتائج
بالتصوير الصحفي من احداث التظاهرات كانت
كلش كل جميله
وانت شو رايك في هواي صحتك تقريبا اول ما
نشرت لي مجله التايم وهذا كان فتحها بس كل
كبيره لي
هاي الصوره كذلك من التظاهرات
تعرفون التظاهرات طول السنه كامله فانت
يوميه تروح على نفس المكان على نفس
الاحداث المفروض اطلع فالصور جديده اطلع
فيد في التكوين جديد كنت ابدل بالعدسات
حتى اقدر ااا
اطلع تكوين جديد هاي الصوره بعدس همم وايد
سوبر وايت وهنانا المتظاهر جاي يركض عليه
يقول لي ليش جاي يتصور فخلي يد على
الكاميرا وانا بسرعه هي دست على الشتاء
فحصلت هاي الصوره
هاي الصوره نفس الشيء غيرتها شويه من
اعدادات الكاميرا
وطلعت هذه الصوره
الصوره الصحفيه اللي يميزها عن بقيه
المحاور عن المحاور الفنيه الثانيه عن
تصوير اللاند سكي بصوره الصحفيه ما ممكن
نعيدها يعني اليوم انت رياضيين هنا ملاكم
مثلا جاي جاي
وضربوا هناك وانت ما حصلت الصوره فما ممكن
تقول عيد اللكمه وتورم الوجه مال صاحبه
منها علامات حصلت الصوره فهذا التحدي
بالصوره الصحفيه يختلف عن المحاور الثانيه
خلال ثلاث سنوات شلون نقل الصوره عن
البصره نقلت الجانب السلبي اللي موجود في
المدينه من تلوث من من احداث بالتظاهرات
بس بالمقابل اكو صوره ايجابيه بالمدينه
وقصوره حلوه ممكن تقدر تنقلها للعالم
الخارجي البصره بشكل عام الاعلام العالمي
يعرف بان هي بس مدينه مال نفط ومدينه مال
النزاعات عشائريه ومدينه بس مليانه تلوث
بس بالمقابل لا انا شفت اكو هواي صور
جميله هاي الصوره من شط العرب
هذه هنانه كانت لحظه مثاليه بصراحه
هاي الصوره اهم من شط العرب
هاي الصوره كانت من ضمن افضل صور للسنه
الجديده 2020 من كورنيش البصره
[تصفيق]
هاي صوره الصياد من الفاو
وهاي الصوره هسه بالتراب الاخيره قدرت
توظف التكوين ووظف الجو الطقس اللي كان
موجود بالبصره بس طلعت بصوره مميزه
شلون بديت اشوف الاشياء والتفاصيل بصراحه
كل مصور
راح يشوف الاشياء مو مثل ما تشوف الانسان
العادي اللي ما عنده هوايه بالتصوير ما
عندها خبره بالتصوير
ضليت انا اشوف من اباه على الفيلم ظليت
بالكادر اللي موجود في الفيلم اشوف كل كل
فريق من الفريمات مات الفيلم اشوفها صوره
الناس العاديين يشوفون القمر بهذه الطريقه
كل كل قمر مكتمل اما انا ضليت اشوفها بهذه
الصوره
[تصفيق]
هذا هنا ملعب البصره
ووو
وكانت يعني صوره ناجحه وانتشرت بهواي
الصحف وحتى صحف رياضيه وكتبت على الملعب
البصره من خلال هذه الصوره
هاي الصوره نفس الشيء انا كل ما يكتمل
شكرا
كل ما يكتمل القمر انا اروح امشي وعيني بس
على السماء لحد ما اشوف القمر ويا فتشي
ممكن اقدر اصوره فهذه هناك بصراحه
اندعمت بالشبه اللي موجوده
عندي صور ناجحه واي من المصورين يعرف
هاي الصوره هناك كانت التحدي الاكبر الي
بتصوير القمر من وراء ما انتشرت شفت اكو
هواي صحف مهتمه بكل اكتمال القمر يعني اكو
هواي صحف
تهتم بالفلك تهتم
بهاي الامور فقلت انا شفت انكم مصوره هنا
عراقي يصور يصور القمر والطياره لازم
يدخلها للصحافه هاي الصوره الصحفيه لازم
تنتشر فبالليت سته شهران على طول سته اشهر
احط الكاميرا مالتي وحط الاسكان حتى
تتعامد الصوره مالت الطياره حتى تتعامد
الطياره القمر وقدرت تصور هاي الصوره
[تصفيق]
الغروب والشروق في المدينه كذلك
هاي الصوره قبل اجرب التصوير الصحفي كنت
اجي اركب هواي صور حتى اطلع بيته صوره بس
من ظليت استمر بالتصوير وعرفت شلون اصور
هذه الصوره من فريم واحد من صوره واحده
بدون اي تركيب
اي اوك شنو الجديد فوتوشوب هاي الكلمه
اللي سمعتها كلش هواي يعني من التعليقات
حتى من الاصدقاء ويعني الاصدقاء وهو ايناس
يصور ويعدل بالفوتوشوب الصوره الصحفيه
ممنوع عندنا تتعامل يعني او تركب
بالفوتوشوب
[موسيقى]
مثل الوكاله اللي انا اشتغل فيها وكاله
الصحافه الفرنسيه او الوكالات الثانيه
الصور الصحفيه الناجحه هي اللي تفهمها كل
اللغات
الصوره حتى تحصل صوره صحفيه ناجحه المفروض
بيها بيها مشاعر
هاي الصوره
[تصفيق]
هاي الصوره بصراحه يعني هواي مؤذيه هناك
شهداء هاي مال تفجيرات البصره الاخيره
اللي صارت بالكيا في هناك قدرت انقل اكو
اكو حدث واكو فيها مشاعر وكل دماء
هاي الصوره نفس الحاله اكو بيها مشاعر
باداره تنقل المشاعر مال هذا الطفل
بالاضافه الى اكو هناك شيء كل شيء يجذب
اللي هي جنطه اليونيسيفك وطفوله
[تصفيق]
هذه الصوره نفس الحاله اكو بها مشاعرك
وبيا مشاعر سعاده وبها البيئه اللي عايشين
بها الاطفال
شلون انا عرفت بالطريقه الصح انا ضليت
اصور بس ما ادري شنو انا مصور صحفي ناجح
لو مو ناجح
كانت سنه 2021 من يعني عرفت بروحي بان انا
مصور لي اسمي داخل الوكاله اللي يشتغل
بيها الوكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه بها تقريبا
ازيد من يمكن الف مصور حول العالم يغطي
هذه الصوره اختاروها وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه من افضل 100 صوره حول العالم من
يمكن الف مصور حول العالم يغطي هاي الصوره
اختاروها وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه من افضل
100 صوره حول العالم
اختاروا هاي الصوره من افضل الصور حول
العالم وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
سنه 2009 كنت رايح رايح الكربله وماخذه
هاي الكاميرا نفسها
بالسيطره قريب السيطره مع الكربله شوف
الدوري المصورين اول ما اجت عيني على
كاميراتهم
فيعني بوقتها بصراحه
مصور صحفي مجرد بس يوثق بالكاميرا مالته
2019 هذا زميلي نفس اللي كان يصور بكربلاء
حاليا هو زميلي وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه
والكاميرا اللي كان شايلها عندي من نفس
الفئه مالتها بالوقت الحالي
[تصفيق]
واثق حياتك بدون رتوش تشوفون الصوره
الصحفيه مثل ما قلت لكم ما بيها اي اي كذب
ما بيها اي فوتوشوب هاي الصوره الوحيده
اللي عندي
2003 كانت ويا والدي الله يحفظه المفروض
هاي الصوره انا هنا كنت همم يمكن عمري هنا
16 سنه كنا هنا نبيع مجالات وجرائد بسوق
الجمهوريه
تمنيت لو موت بقيه اللحظه موفق ذيك
الصعوبات بس بصراحه ما كانت لكم كانيه وما
كانت اكو كاميرات فهذه الصوره الوحيده
اللي عندي عندي يعني من مدينه انا ابيع
مجلات الجرائد بصراحه اللي يريد اقوله وثق
حياتك مثل ما هي راح ترجع فد 20 30 سنه
راح ترجع على الصوره مالتك وراح تتمنى لو
انك مصورها صوره حقيقيه بدون فوتوشوب
وبدون فلاتر لين راح من تكبر راح تقول مو
هذا شكل الحقيقي مو هي حياتي اللي كنت انا
عايش راح تقتنع بين الحياه اللي كانت
عائشه كلها
قيمتها الصوره الصحفيه لها قيمتها
حسين اللي كان يبيع جرائد من بعد 19 سنه
صار اسمه موجود باشهر الجرايد
هاي صحيفه الجارديان اللي تنتبيعها
كانت جرائد مستخدمه هاي صحيفه الجاردين
وهذه الاسبانيه
[تصفيق]
مجلات وصعب خلال هذه الايام اللي فاتت هاي
الجارديان وهاي البي بي سي هاي نيوز ويك
ناشيونال جيوغرافيك
قصه حسين فارس
[تصفيق]